[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we wanted to do a historical top 50
of uh
chess players of sort of all time and to
to do that we are using um the
statistics by
jeff sonex who has created a site called
chess matrix we've gotten some help from
frank hofmeister who is know just his
story and
then we have still kind of added our own
touch
and it's always gonna be subjective and
there's simply there's no correct answer
i hope you guys
enjoyed and i hope you agree with every
single
ranking because usually many public
lists what could go wrong who would
disagree with anything
but yeah it's been it's been fun and i
hope you like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening and uh welcome to round
five of ultrabox norwich has tournament
2020
and i'm peter svidler and i am feeling
very very big shoes today
uh judith is doing her uh festival
things
uh that must be wonderful and in some
way i feel
sad not to be there but i'm also very
happy to be here uh
for this one round uh joined of course
by
world champion vladimir kramnik uh who
will be
handling the chess matters i will be
basically clicking on the screen
somewhere
uh should be an exciting day ahead and
i'm
i'm very happy to uh to be here to talk
about
uh talk about it with with vladimir
good evening good afternoon uh everyone
it's uh
very uh nice for me to meet my good old
friend peter and to work with him for
for a few hours i know that is
one of the best commentators in the
world which can maybe
compensate my
[Music]
abilities in this matter and my
english because peter peter's english is
almost perfect
we will uh game i think is the fastest
game ferris but
um young shirt has somewhat unsurprising
there's a very interesting game between
uh firojin and tari but i think the one
i
sort of look forward the most is the
game between fabian and levon
probably if i if i had to pick one it's
probably the uh the corona running game
i agree i agree but uh also for magnus
has to be careful he has black
and you know there is i know myself yeah
when you play such tournaments that
somebody is out of form but he's still a
very strong player you have black
so you you want to play for a win you
want to try to win it but
uh you also know that you shouldn't
overstep the you know the limit because
duda is a very strong grand master yeah
and it's quite
interesting for me i want to see um
what kind of opening magnus is going to
play and how is he going to play
really sharp and trying really to win by
all means
or he will try to you know to play and
to try to grab his chance if he gets one
uh because yeah in such situations
you have to be careful i think you
shouldn't be over optimistic
because well young christoph
can strike at any moment and
especially with white his he is usually
very good
and you have to be really careful so
let's see it's an interesting game in my
opinion yeah and
and also considering the start young
sister had in this tournament he clearly
has nothing to lose and
uh people people in that frame of mind
they could be extremely dangerous
because
i think the best uh it's very you know
easy for us to give advice because we
don't have to play having lost
you know three classical games in an
armageddon but
i think the way he could repair his
tournament from here on out
would be to just kind of completely
ignore the results and just
go there to to express himself because
he is as vladimir correctly said he is a
very strong player he is a very
imaginative player and
in a way i think for instance his white
game against levon
was i maybe could have done this because
you know this is much more the way i
approach chess artist i used to approach
this
but for somebody like him just going
there with the white pieces trying to
make up
somewhat boring draw it just doesn't
suit him at all he is
an attacking player he is he generally
doesn't do this at all and it seemed he
wasn't just
just he was quite uncomfortable you know
playing this kind of chess so
i expect him to return uh to his uh
normal approach today and uh yes
and i just want to add that i think for
him it's a great opportunity to save the
tournament today yeah because
if he manages to win uh which is always
possible of course then and whatever
will be the final result uh
in a way that his tournament will be
saved yeah
so he might be extremely motivated today
and i expect him to play
shark to play for a win today i uh
that's my feeling so
uh that's going to be really interesting
and what do you think about ferocity
game
well i'm i'm slightly biased because
i've uh
uh aryanis is somebody i
i have had well
it's my my only real coaching experience
you know coaching
in quotation marks i guess but i've i've
worked with with
aryan a little bit in the past and i i
really want to see him do well but i
think with the black pieces against
alireza he starts
he starts as an underdog clearly but
it's it's going to be very very
interesting because you never really
know from the outside
the dynamics of younger players of a
similar age right because
i still have some players i've played in
when we were kids
who i perhaps now you know outraged by
quite a long distance and i still
struggle playing against them because
those childhood memories they
still exist and nothing overrides them
so i'm not entirely sure what the
dynamics are between between those two
and if
if if there is even any dynamics
existing but
uh perhaps aryan just doesn't feel you
know that
he has anything to worry there and it's
it's very possible i think when
when you talk about young players
playing each other
well in general young players have a
tendency not to worry
too much about any opponent yeah
yeah i think that's fair and so let's
come back to the
uh old lions yeah uh
if you can call it i mean for this
tournament the old lions karwana ranian
so what what do you think bishop before
d5
no i think probably the nimzo uh
but yeah i wouldn't want to to bet the
like the entire house on it but
and and the fact that that levon is
still thinking is yeah exactly
that is why because usually okay usually
i think he plays nymphs and he would
have
immediately very quickly play bishop
before but he starts to think so who
knows who knows
uh
yeah there it is and and fabi instantly
goes f3 which is very very sharp and
very uh you know aggressive systems so
which clearly means he is
he's in a very fighting mood and he
wants to play for a win
you know i mean without any
safety uh uh on his position because
black has a
big choice here of different lines
and quite a few lines extremely sharp
uh so very interesting game most
probably
we are going yeah i think it's it's very
possible that we get a
sharp and clear game here and perhaps
one of the the last games
you know considering how uh you know
everybody's life has gone in 2020
maybe the the very last notable
classical chess game
played in 2020 until this one in this
system
is the game favi played against kirill
alexander in the candidates where
uh where he beat carriel who uh
basically i was there i i know what
happened he uh
he had detailed notes on the line and he
just mixed up move orders and as you
mentioned
in such a concrete variation if if you
go for something very principled and
then
you mix up something uh very often it
will just cost you the game which is
what happened there
he more or less made one mistake in that
game and that and that mistake ended up
being completely decisive
yeah exactly the same story have
happened to me when i played my last
tournament i can't say a year ago
uh yeah i've played with widget and
exactly the same story i've just
confused the move order and all of a
sudden it was just so bad that
the damage was totally unrepairable yeah
so this line is very sharp yeah
and i see some familiar position for
both of us peter something very familiar
in the game
duda carlson yeah this is this is cute
because
i i keep on expecting people will stop
doing this
but it's not happening somehow it's just
a line that
continues continues being discussed at
the very top level
yes yes i mean it uh
i think peter you've played bishop city
yeah
i i i feel like bishop e3 is clever but
maybe it's uh
let's show the let's show the opening
for those of our viewers who perhaps
don't really recognize the position
instantly this is the karo khan
specifically with knight f6 and eta xf6
which i think maybe even two years ago
was virtually
non-existent yeah yeah i mean existent
but
barely breathing you know on uh
in reanimation yeah somehow yeah
and then yeah it seems to be quite
playable uh in
in particular i think because of
magnus's efforts because magnus uh was
clearly the most high profile player to
start playing it and
the reason for my insistence to play
bishop p3 here
is i want to preserve the option of
meeting h5 with knight f3
which stops h4 i don't know if this is
clever or not but this was my
my reasoning because after 1992 which is
what uh
young schistos ended up doing they do
very often play
uh h5 here and this i think displayed
this is the new development which you
know this is the change
which was i think uh thought of very
recently and the
one of the major reasons why the line is
considered playable
because i think the big point is if the
pawn reaches the h4 square the knight on
e2
uh becomes uh a lot more difficult you
know to
uh you you kind of struggle to find good
squares for it because normally it goes
to g3 and then it starts going to f5 to
e4
uh to places like that and uh
with upon h4 all these things are of
course much uh
much harder well frankly to my taste
it's just
uh cannot be good but i'm too
conservative yeah i mean i don't believe
in this line at all
uh i've played it with peter in the last
tournament
i was about to start laughing
uncontrollably because you were much
better by movie
i was much better very quickly but
basically all my
opening knowledge there was that i've
seen couple of games that they were
doing it and then bishop d6
and k8 and some and sometimes h5 i mean
that was all i knew
about it and peter played bishop e3 so
it was not the first time you've played
bishop e3
no i played it against magnus and this
was i was totally unaware
of this no magnus actually played this
line against me in the european
uh club cup in 20 i want to say 18
and uh i ended up almost winning that
game which was kind of surprising
considering
i started zero out of four in that
tournament but uh
yeah for hp3 exists but i think almost
nobody else does it
but now yes i i mean okay normally it's
uh
again i'm maybe too conservative or
too extreme but normally you just cannot
simply
double your poems and for no real
compensation
and try to pretend that you are
perfectly fine
but of course times are changing uh
you know understanding of chess is also
changing
and uh probably it's not so bad as it
looks
it to me it looks really bad yeah
it's it's it's always been slightly
strange to me that that this is somehow
playable but i think results show that
it
it's not as bad as you would expect if
you
as as you described if you just like
approach it uh
with a classical viewpoint white has a
very solid structural advantage all the
end games will be
uh to put it mildly extremely unpleasant
for black
there's also a pawns yeah especially the
pawn in india
and and also it's not clear how you're
not getting mated on the king side
particularly if you play h5 and white i
don't know get some kind of h3 and g4
playing
uh but the results appear to indicate
that this is
at the very least playable so let's see
how how it goes for magnus
and at least one prediction we've made
so far has come true because
young schist of already castled queen
side which is i think the most
you know the most principled way of an
aggressive way of playing
and and frankly also quite logical yeah
i mean absolutely yeah
but it's just very happy to see all that
because uh as i mentioned i think
uh he is much better off playing like
this today
than trying to play something safe and
uh
hoping to i don't know make a draw
player play in armageddon
yeah so let's move to to the kids as we
as we call them with judith
yeah let's see the kids yeah the kids
are playing in italian
where i would really like to shut up and
let vladimir speak because i
everybody has been playing the italian
for the past five years and i still
have no idea about move orders or you
know frankly anything
but you know peter the problem is that
even the very experienced players who
played with both scholars like myself
we also are getting know that i i was
also getting confused with
more folders because it's so strange and
so many different nuances that
sometimes i would get confused even if
i've played i don't know how many games
with
i think well this movefodder what can i
uh
say about it um black is playing h6
sometimes
as early as possible just to avoid
bishop g5 lines here which are very
sharp
but it gives white an opportunity which
i think i've used couple of times myself
to avoid uh playing h3 because now for
instance you can
actually play knight bd2 without h3
which
which is not all a4 first and then
knight bd2 because now
knight g4 typical uh maneuver is not
working anymore rook d2
uh usually black is playing king h8 and
after h3 he has this
square of on h6 for the knight and then
he's going f5 and
it's supposed to be good for black now
to make our viewers completely confused
i will mention that the move f5 exists
in all these types of positions
but but still usually after ef there is
knight h6 yeah
is is an option but uh yeah so h6 now
white can try
to uh to gain a half temp
because most probably sooner or later he
will have to play h3 but
to start with knight bd2 immediately or
after a45 for example
and uh that might give him a chance to
transfer his knight to g3
quicker and then he might even avoid
playing h3 and get the center so
that's uh the point of of this move
order so i would have
i think i was trying not to hurry with
h6 even if
given bishop g5 line i mean this line is
very sharp and interesting for white but
because of that reason but uh we will
see maybe it doesn't
make a very big difference here i think
the interesting point is that iron so
far
is completely ignoring both a6 and a5
which is
something like we were taught to do uh
at as early as possible i think when
when i was i was a an e45 player as
black
my entire life and uh when
you know discussing the italian we were
told to play a6 as early as possible
just to never have to worry about the
bishop on c5 so
you know one way to justify what what
black is doing here
is to say that he is also trying to save
on something that costs a tempo and if
as you've mentioned white often plays a4
these days
then i think black plays a5 and black is
quite happy because
as we uh as we have seen in the past
years
i think pioneered by alexander grishouk
black
sometimes plays a6 and then responds to
a4 with a5
losing a full tempo and even those
positions are somehow quite playable for
black so
uh getting this without the loss of
over tempo is maybe acceptable for black
that's true it's only
i start to think that if white is clever
so to say
play started with knight bd2 here uh i'm
not quite sure if black has uh
anything better than if he wants to put
his pawn on a6
yeah because now a5 line maybe is not so
good anymore because knight f1 will come
directly and here it's very important
this h3 tempo because
he has to be so maybe if playing knight
bd2 would be clever
uh also there is another interesting
line for black which is very fashionable
after knight bd2
is i mean in general in uh as as a plan
is to play bishop b6 97
but here already black will be not in
time because white goes bishop b3 for
example and then 97 knight c4
black is not in time to uh to get his
bishop
to c7 yeah after c6 so i think knight
bd2 is
to me looks like a very clever uh idea
to yeah i i would suspect it's it's the
the most principled way to
uh to try and uh use the fact that h6
has been placed yeah that's that would
be my
my guess that knight bd2 is probably the
best move probably black
will play a6 then
and who knows maybe there is a chance
for white to even to
to try to manage without
bishop b3 or a4 maybe even to play
knight f1 first
yeah this this structure is what i
wanted to to ask you about because i
think you've had games like this right
we go before knight takes c4 xc5
knight a5 c takes d6 i guess i don't
know maybe
[Music]
it's uncomfortable for black i always
thought like a4 and that's
like h3 that might be quite
uncomfortable because it's almost
impossible
for black to get d5 yeah because e5 pawn
is weak
so maybe after knight f1 black yeah i
mean
white might get some good version of
of this italian slightly improved
version than usual even if it doesn't
really change
so much the assessment of the position
and
probably it is well close to equal ah by
the way wait i think
that's exactly the move order i've
played against magnus carlsen in
in in this invitational tournament with
black
some uh in the first game i'm not
actually and you ended up you ended up
having not a very good version yeah i
ended up having a slightly worse version
of a typical position and i i think it
was like that but
yeah don't really remember exactly so
let's see all those
no he played h3 so he just wants to
transpose i guess to the main theory
yeah because if black now plays a6
a5 for bishop d6 it would probably
transpose yeah
i think in most cases yeah we just we
just get the main line theory now and
knight bg2 was
i i wouldn't say it's necessarily
stronger but it was a way to maybe try
and uh you know gain something using the
the move order
that's exactly yeah exactly what what
your
expressing uh peter before that you know
all those small folders very difficult
to
to understand and to even for
experienced players and probably if he
is not so experienced yes in italian to
you know to get this very delicate move
further so probably he just
wants to to uh to trans to trans
transfer
you know to the position he knows yeah
yeah i think i think it makes practical
sense for sure yep just to
just to steer the game towards uh
something he he prepared this morning
and not
not bother very much with uh trying to
improve upon it
so yeah this is an a6 as you predicted
played quite quickly by aryan now that
he provoked h3
i think we can leave this one to develop
foreign
still you know it will not end uh uh
very
soon yeah in this game yeah it seems
like it seems like they're discussing
something that
uh first of all yeah both of them
are reasonably comfortable with and
secondly
i think is by far the quietest of the
three games we have today
because the other the other two look
potentially a lot sharper at least for
now
yeah and uh but even this one can get i
mean
what i like that it's a complicated game
and most probably it will be a long and
interesting game i mean
because position is quiet for for now
but uh
it will be probably i mean yeah it will
not be a short draw that's for sure